the organizers of the oscars say that
will smith was asked to leave the award
ceremony after slapping chris rock but
he refused let's just remind you of the
moment
i'm out here oh richard
oh wow
wow
will smith just smack out of me
wow dude
yes it was a g.i jane joe keep my wife's
name
out
i'm going to okay
[Music]
well after going on to win the uh best
actor oscar he was seen dancing and
singing to his own song summertime at
the oscars vanity fair after party
and chris rock was seen for the first
time last night arriving at his own gig
he reportedly told the audience he's
still processing what happened let's get
the latest should be from our us
correspondent greg milam
there have been a lot of questions about
why something wasn't done at the time of
this incident and it's clear the academy
was as taken by surprise as everyone
else who was watching
things unfolded in a way we could not
have anticipated they say in a statement
they do say though that will smith was
asked to leave the ceremony after that
incident but refused they also say that
they recognized they could have handled
things differently they are now taking
action though with these disciplinary
proceedings uh for violating the code of
conduct they say inappropriate physical
contact uh abusive or threatening
behavior they accuse will smith of the
potential punishments for that go right
up to expulsion from the academy now in
modern times that has only happened to
the likes of harvey weinstein roman
polanski people who are guilty of
serious sexual offenses of course so
that is seen as being unlikely to happen
also the suggestion that will smith
could have that oscar taken back
again seen as unlikely it's only
happened once in the history of the
academy whoopi goldberg who is an
academy governor has said it's not going
to happen in this case the most likely
result will be some sort of temporary
suspension perhaps a reprimand but will
smith has two weeks to respond before
his fate is decided at a board meeting
in the middle of april we should also
say that chris rock who was on the other
end of that slap of course has been back
on stage as a stand-up comic he says
he's still processing what happened on
that oscars stage